now to the second part it's quite
different so it's tone mapping this is
concerned in all so before we had
optimization for the light simulation
now we looked at the very end of our
rendering pipeline so the issue of
showing the image output on a display
because the problem is that a light
simulation outputs radians so it's the
how much light travels along one
direction when it comes from a small
surface patch so you collect radians
with your camera recorded but somehow
your display expects RGB values so the
radians can carry some color information
so you could for example trace the arc
the G to B value general independently
you can do something with more fidelity
like spectral retracing so your trace
rays that we're not only radiance is
carried along the Ray but spectral
radiance so radians of a certain
wavelength of the light this for example
you can see this effect in a prisons
where you split white light into rainbow
colors so if you do not perform spectral
ray tracing clear and just assume we
have white radiance then you cannot
simulate this effect because then the
refraction so the rate geometry changes
with the wavelength that's associated to
it so your refraction angels get
different and this causes to split into
the rainbow colors so but in some way
you have radiance as a output
so to show them on this place or to
print them you need to convert your
images somehow from radians to RGB and
there is a inherent problem with that
because radians of light simulation have
a huge range because they try to
simulate real-world physics and in real
world you have a huge difference between
dark and bright so for example if you
take the ratio between the surf between
our surface at a ground level in the
earth atmosphere that is either
illuminated by the Sun or the moon
the difference is effect of eight
hundred thousand and then imagine that
the patch on the ground is either white
or black this causes another difference
in the reflected radiance quantities of
approximately a factor of 100 so if you
want to say a general light simulation
and you can expect that illumination by
Sun and Moon should be in there white
and black surfaces should also be in
there you have to somehow cold with a
ratio between the darkest and the
brightest values of 80 million so is it
relevant to do that so can people even
see the difference between that and yes
they can so since these are highly
relevant features of our world to
differentiate dark from bright
especially under very bright and dark
conditions so imagine a caveman in the
woods at night it would be very good to
see small contrast differences that
could indicate predators so there was a
revolutionary forcing to today to
develop a visual system that also can
take advantage of this huge dynamic
range of Radiance values so for example
how does this build up so photoreceptors
in our eyes
they have chemical bleaching when they
are hit by light particles so this can
be regulated biochemically to enable
adaptation in a range of 2 orders of
magnitude so just by regulating the
biochemical properties of photoreceptors
you can adapt the eye to a brain to a
difference in darken prior to 100 the
pupil size gives you another order of
magnitude so a factor of 10 and the
neural adaptation is more or less the
signal processing so what to do actually
with the changing signal because your
receptors get bleached so the dynamic
range of human vision is approximately
100 million so that means that we can
perceive in fact the dynamic range of
realistic conditions on in our
atmosphere but then you have so the
output of a light simulation if it takes
this into account can be I can have a
difference of 80 million or affect of 80
million between dark and bright and then
you want to show this on a display so
the technology for a standard display
gives you a dark to bright ratio of
approximately 1000 and if you use 8-bit
encoding of your values then you only
have 265 values
when it beat James that means that
somehow our technology is immensely
inadequate to show realistic scenarios
in some way this is also good because
you get not blinded by your display but
we have to somehow account for that so
just taking the radiant output and
converting it trivially to images we
carry some problems with it but usually
you have you split them into two
different coloring
so you have eight Peaks for our 8 bits
48 beautiful P and you can somehow
imagine that this gives you how much red
light is at this pixel and yeah you
talked to hundreds I mean of course for
the whole color K mode you have more
values but if you just look at the dark
bright ratio of a single color this is
approximately what you have so now tone
mapping is the method that was developed
to combat this problem so the output of
a light simulation has already said high
dynamic range because of the real-world
dynamic range of brightness values and
these play devices usually have a lot of
emic range so what we need to do is to
compress the range of output somehow and
this is referred to as Ida tone mapping
a tone reproduction so these are the
names that you find in the literature so
there are two sub issues here one is
range compression so how to convert high
dynamic range luminance to low dynamic
range luminance this is the content of
this lecture and
then you still have lumen answers but
usually there are standardized color
spaces in which images are stored so you
don't store your own whole Brune formats
which take certain wavelength and then
gives the luminance values for tools but
they are standardized ways to do that
and this is covered in a different
lecture about color you see the extra
number here so I refer you to this
lecture if you want to know more about
the color in here now I only explain
range compression to some extent so now
a graphic example so here we have a
bright a simple bright light source with
no ambient light in the scene that means
that all contrast comes only from this
one light source by a global
illumination so if you take if you would
photograph the scene and take a short
exposure this is what you get so all the
dimly illuminated parts completely
disappear in black and but you see
details in previously to bright scenes
so that led to overexposure of your
camera so for example here you now see
the outline so the simulate of the bulb
for example a very long exposure leads
to overexposure of most of the image so
you do not see any detail anymore close
to the lamp or add directly luminate
that surfaces but what you see is that
previously Tim Lee illuminated objects
in the background now are very
perceivable so this
is what you get if you take only small
parts of your dynamic range and map
those to an image and what could you do
to combine all this information into one
image so that the most trivial thing you
can imagine is I just divide by the
maximum of the scene
this gives me a nice luminance values
from 0 to 1 and this I can map to
whatever range I want the problem with
this is that usually the maximum is not
indicative of the whole scene the
maximum is usually extremely bright so
when you're divided by the maximum the
only thing you see is a simple
reflection in the close to the light
bulb if you clamp it so let's say I have
a range of luminances that I'm
interested in everything below is
described by a serial everything above
my maximum that I decide to have is
completely white this is exactly the
problem
that's that becomes obvious with high
dynamic range that parts are
underexposed other parts always post so
clamping also doesn't get you something
you have to take the whole range you
cannot just ignore certain parts so one
approach that gives you nice results is
exponential mapping they are USU
exponential distribution in your arm
luminance values and then rescale this
exponential function into a linear one
that means that very bright values gets
came down low values gets came up but
you you account for the very bright
spots so these are the things that gets
changed the most so the price values at
the PAL get some reasonable white but
they do not dominate the whole scene
a more sophisticated approach is the
Rhinehart
tone mapper developed by Reinhart Takei
and this is this is the one example that
we'll present in this lecture as you can
imagine there are many tone necklace so
everyone tried some approach that works
very well for a certain subset of scenes
some methods were optimized to for
parallel hardware or for certain
hardware architectures to give more
speed there some percentage rough
approximation that work in real time so
there is already a quite wide bunch of
tone may pose to choose from and terrain
Houghton maple is one of the most common
so it if you're looking to us on an open
source or commercial rendering software
this is usually one of the things that
is implemented so and there is also some
additional information to put this into
context there is some some approach in
digital photography to take multiple
exposure images so to combine exposures
of the same scene that are taken with
different exposure times into one image
so this is called high dynamic range
photography and usually to use similar
methodologies so the Rhinehart on mapper
can also be used to combine or for HDR
photography but if you put HDR
photography into
we'll usually end up with images like
that and this is not what America's
about tone mapping is a perceptually and
physically validated approach that gives
you realistic impressions of the scene
and it's not an artistic effect so it's
not that you take tone mapping look at
the image and say I would like to have
it to have more contrast in there and
then you change your tone member I mean
this is not in standard use and the
community of HDR photography to a large
extent over uses this capability of the
system for example this photograph here
is a completely botched implementation
or use of HDR range compression for
example things that you see that are not
correct the he knows around the balloons
so suddenly why the sky is brighter
around the silhouettes of the balloons
this is this is a an effect that is
present in the visual system to some
extent but not to this extent so this is
some people think that this is nice nice
HDR photography but this is just wrong
simply estate if you like that your
images look like that then this is a
artists decision not Tom epic this was
just yeah contrast enhancement you can
totally worth it
also the colors in this image get
screwed up because they are not
oversaturated
but this is just a warning the tone
mapping that you encounter for light
simulations should not look like that
because then you have area in your
application yeah
I mean this this is a combination of
different cultures now it's I mean it is
a combination of different exposures and
it's taken with a tone mapping approach
and you have to do the combination
somehow it said before you can add a
device but it makes a movement combined
clamping but usually the total network
if you a more realistic result and for
example why is it obvious that here
already multiple exposures were combined
because in the very left of the left
when you moon you see that you still see
some kind of detail in the route in
behind but at the same time use you can
always directly look into the Sun
without it having cleared half the
screen so that means that already a huge
dynamic range was compressed here but it
should not look like that it should look
like that if it's done correctly and
this would be the correct application
for this photograph so it looks a whole
realistic it doesn't over saturate the
colors
it only has a very light halo around the
cigarettes which is also an effect
that's present in the vision system so
this is what you should aim for so now
about tone mapping itself and there are
two large different classes so one of
the global tone mappers and the other
local so the global tone map was use a
mapping function that converts radiance
at a certain pixel to say RTP value if
you select this color space and this
mapping functions uniform
what I mean here is not that it's
uniform it produces the uniform ultimate
value so you don't get an image with a
single color value but that the function
itself just takes as input the radiance
at a certain pixel and outputs are
appealing and this function is then used
for pixels in the image more complex
methodologies are local tone APIs which
not only take the single pixel into
account but also it's in via its
neighbors this is this is perceptually
motivated because if you have seen
before this contrast or brightness
adaptation of your eyes in the in the
photoreceptors for example this is done
locally so a single photoreceptor
attempts to different brightnesses so
that means that you told mapping in the
human eye is a local behavior but there
are there reasons to employ both of them
so the global tone mappers they are fast
because they have a single mapping
function so you take you can execute
this function purely on each pixel so
this makes it perfectly usable for a GPU
approaches for example but you incur
some loss of detail because you cannot
locally look as if the is this already a
dark patch of machine so I can enhance
the contrast more there or is it at a
dark bright boundary where I do not do
it that much and the local don't map
does allow this so they allow a local
contrast enhancement but your slope
because you not only have to
say look at the pixel but also it's
neighborhood the neighborhood grows
quadratically if you enlarge it so
anti-air you will incur a different
complexity in your problem